liebe kolleginnen und kollegen herzlich
willkommen zu unserer pressekonferenz
auf der das neue forschungsnetzwerk zur
behandlung und erforschung von kuwait 19
vorgestellt werden soll in die nächsten
minuten die unsere pressekonferenz wird
per livestream übertragen
es gibt die möglichkeit für journalisten
während der pressekonferenz und
schriftlich fragen zuzuschicken
ich darf begrüßen herren als unsere
gäste freuen uns sehr dass sie die zeit
haben herr professor krömer sie sind
vorstandsvorsitzende der charité hier in
berlin und wir begrüßen auch und freuen
uns auch dass sie gekommen sind herr
professor drosten direktor des instituts
für biologie der charité herzlich
willkommen
frau ministerin bitte beginnen sie mit
ihrem die durch das corona virus
verursachte cupid 19 pandemie stellt
deutschland vor die größte
herausforderung seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg und die hauptlast in diesem
kampf gegen die pandemie tragen die
kliniken und alle die dort arbeiten vom
chefarzt bis hin zu den pflegekräften
und natürlich auch nicht zu vergessen
bis hin zu den hausmeistern und lieber
herr professor krömer lieber professor
drosten ich darf ihnen danke sagen
einmal für ihre arbeit aber natürlich
auch dafür dass sie jetzt heute hier
sind
und gerade die charité zählt zu den
führenden universitätskliniken in
unserem land und die uni kliniken haben
wir das besondere merkmal das die
versorgungs und forschungskompetenz
bündeln und das genau da eine
strukturierte zusammenarbeit zwischen
versorgung von kranken und der forschung
von enormem vorteil ist gerade in der
jetzigen situation
ich freue mich dass ich mit ihnen
niemeyer krömer lieber drosten diese
initiative heute zum aufbau eines
forschungsnetzwerkes für die
universitätsmedizin vorstellen kann
denn die initiative bei der bewältigung
der pandemie und damit bei der
behandlung von vielen schwerkranken wird
eine wichtige schlüsselrolle ein
die idee zu der initiative die wir heute
gemeinsam vorstellen
stammt von ihnen aber das will ich an
dieser stelle auch nicht verhehlen
sie ist auf einen anruf unserer
bundeskanzlerin zurückzuführen die
gesagt hat menschen dieser situation
haben die universitätskliniken eine ganz
wichtige aufgabe und können wir da noch
etwas tun und diese initiative
unterstützen wir natürlich aus unserem
haus heraus gern denn am ende steht fest
dass wir jetzt die wirksamsten ideen und
konzepte brauchen um die patientinnen
und patienten möglichst bestmöglich zu
versorgen und gleichzeitig die menschen
zu schützen die diese versorgung leisten
die deutschen universitätskliniken
stehen bei der entwicklung dieser ideen
und konzepte an herausragender stelle
wir haben exzellente expertise und warum
sollen wir sie nicht noch besser nutzen
als bisher schon
und deswegen wollen wir ein netzwerk
aufbauen und die koordinierung des
netzwerkes wird von der charité
übernommen
folgendes ist geplant zuerst wird eine
nationale task force eingerichtet
dabei sind der bund in form unseres
hauses also des bundesministeriums für
bildung und forschung aber auch das bmg
bereit sich hier aktiv zu beteiligen und
diese taskforce dient dann der steuerung
und der abstimmung zwischen der
universitätsmedizin und der politik und
auch natürlich werden verschiedene
wissenschaftliche netzwerke mit
einbezogen
es wird also ein ganz ganz enger draht
zwischen wissenschaft und politik
geknüpft obwohl und auch das will ich
hier einmal deutlich sagen wir arbeiten
auch heute schon eng und gut zusammen
noch entscheidender ist aber dass über
diese initiative maßnahmenpläne
diagnostik und behandlungsstrategien
möglichst aller deutscher
universitätskliniken zusammengeführt und
ausgewertet werden sollen
das ziel des ganzen ist dass wir
voneinander und miteinander jetzt im
laufen lernen wie man so schön sagt denn
die korona epidemie ist eine
herausforderung wie sie die
bundesrepublik deutschland noch nicht
erlebt hat
im ergebnis sollen strukturen und
prozesse in kliniken geschaffen werden
die eine möglichst optimale versorgung
der kurve 19 erkrankten sicherstellen
und die universitätskliniken und die
anderen krankenhäuser werden dann
schnell qualitätsgesichert und
schlagkräftig agieren können
der zweite wichtige punkt ist dass
perspektivisch wir hoffen natürlich dass
alle universitätskliniken mitmachen das
perspektivisch an allen
universitätskliniken die daten der
behandelten cupid 19 patienten
systematisch erfasst werden und in einer
datenbank zusammengeführt werden und
zusammengeführt werden damit nämlich
dann die krankengeschichten oder eben
auch die daten zur konstitution der
erkrankten und zu dieser datensammlung
können zusätzliche wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler die nicht in der
medizinischen forschung tätig sind dann
dazu geholt werden und sie werden durch
ihre forschung die arbeit der ärztinnen
und ärzte dann unterstützend flankieren
mit hilfe dieses breiten datensatzes der
da generiert wird werden sicher valide
und sehr nützliche kenntnisse gewonnen
werden können für die individuelle
behandlung der patienten für das
pandemie management aber eben auch für
die impfstoff und für die therapie
entwicklung und sie können und das ist
glaube ich gerade in dieser jetzigen
situation auch wichtig sie können
fortlaufend von allen abgefragt und
genutzt werden wie bei professor krömer
herr professor thorsten ich bin
beeindruckt wie schnell sie es geschafft
haben aus ihrem vorschlag aus der idee
innerhalb doch sehr sehr kurzer zeit ein
belastbares konzept zu entwickeln und
nur deswegen können wir natürlich dann
auch unsere verfahren mit großer
schnelligkeit absolvieren insgesamt um
ihnen ein paar zahlen zu nennen werden
wir für dieses projekt 150 millionen
euro zur verfügung stellen
und ich bin überzeugt dass dieses
einmalige wissenschaftliche projekt
dieses zusammenwirken der verschiedenen
kräfte uns in der behandlung und der
entwicklung von coop 19 wirklichen
großen schritt voranbringen wird
ich darf an dieser stelle ihnen auch
nochmals danke sagen hoffe und wünsche
ihnen natürlich dass sie erfolg haben
und denke dass ich damit im moment für
sehr sehr viele menschen in unserem land
spreche und auch wenn viele menschen
dieses ist jetzt seine echte
belastungsprobe empfinden und ich glaube
es ist auch eine echte belastungsprobe
für unser land ich bin mir ziemlich
sicher dass wissenschaft politik und
gesellschaft im gemeinsamen
zusammenwirken in der lage ist diese
herausforderungen zu bewältigen und der
hass der herausforderung zu bestehen
herzlichen dank herr professor kroupa
bitte von ministerin wir drosten meine
damen und herren möchte zunächst ganz
kurz die frage beantworten warum dieses
programm jetzt so sinnvoll ist und warum
es die unikliniken betrifft die
ministerin hatte schon gesagt dass die
korona krise die deutsche medizin vor
besondere herausforderungen gestellt
ich will das mal ganz kurz am beispiel
der charité einordnen damit das nicht so
im abstrakten bleibt sondern sie konkret
verstehen was aktuell los ist unser
besitzer der senat von berlin hat eine
verordnung erlassen
darin steht krankenhäuser müssen also
wir auch so weit medizinisch vertretbar
grundsätzlich alle planbaren aufnahmen
operationen und angriffe aussetzen
soweit dadurch personelle und sonstige
kapazitäten für die behandlung von
patientinnen und patienten mit co at 19
oder verdacht hier auf freigesetzt
werden das heißt wir haben als sehr
große einrichtung die klare anweisung
nichts zu machen was wir nicht wissen
was heißt das für eine einrichtung wie
die charité
wir machen im moment nur 50 prozent der
üblichen operativen eingriffe wir haben
bestand heute morgen 538 freie betten
davon 114 freie intensivbetten das heißt
wir haben ein ganz ein richtig großes
krankenhaus vorbereitet dafür dass diese
geschichte kommt das ist eingebettet in
ein programm in berlin was dazu führt
dass das hier in berlin die intensiv
kapazität praktisch verdoppelt wird wie
sieht die realität heute morgen aus wir
haben 14 intensivpatienten aktuell das
heißt wir sind im moment in einer
situation dass wir vorbereitet sind auf
eine kommende entwicklung und versuchen
müssen die zeit jetzt maximal zu nutzen
was brauchen wir neben dieser intensiv
kapazität wir brauchen neben der
intensiv kapazität von der alle überall
schreiben das enorm
ticket was auch stimmt eine bessere
diagnostik eine impfung und neue
behandlungsmethoden
meines erachtens kann ich machen gut
kann nicht mal der aus meiner sicht ist
der schlüssel zum zurückfinden in
gesellschaftliche normalität oder einer
der schlüssel besteht darin dass wir
eine sichere medizinische versorgung
anbieten können wenn das erreicht ist
können wir wesentlich besser mit der
geschichte umgehen
jetzt können sich ja fragen wo ist die
kombination von intensiv medizin mit
expertise in forschung also mit
erkenntnisgewinn gibt und die gibt es
eben überwiegend in der unimedizin die
deutsche uni medizin besteht aus 37
hochleistungs kliniken und wenn sich mal
angucken was in diesen kliniken los ist
oder konzentriert ist dann ist über ein
fünftel der intensiv kapazität die wir
jetzt unbedingt brauchen
in hand des staates und zwar in der uni
medizin
es gibt keinen anderen so großen
geschlossenen block auf den eine
institution einfluss hätte wie die
intensiv kapazität in der
universitätsmedizin wir mobilisieren
alle verfügbaren kräfte und müssen
aufpassen deswegen ist dieses programm
so wichtig dass der zweite gewichtige
auftrag nämlich die forschung und neue
behandlungsmethoden impfungen ähnliches
zu generieren nicht aus dem blick gerät
und deswegen ist diese initiative zu
diesem zeitpunkt ungemein wichtig das
bmbf stellt hier zusätzliche
forschungsmittel zur verfügung in einer
zeit wo wir absehbare engpässe haben
werden wir bleiben damit forschungszeit
ich handlungsfähig können ein nationales
flächendeckendes forschungs bündnis
schmieden und die in deutschland
verfügbaren kräfte bündeln
die ministerin hatte schon angedeutet
dass das ist eine nationale task force
gibt und was die so nebenbei gesagt hat
ist ja absolut nicht selbstverständlich
dass alle beteiligten bundesministerien
in einer solchen task-force mitarbeiten
und ihre expertise einbringen und das
ganze soll in enger abstimmung mit dem
rk ii in kurzer zeit aufgebaut und
arbeitsfähig sollen
sowas liefert das ganz konkret was
bringt das was bringt uns das in unserem
täglichen leben wenn die sache
funktioniert
wir telefonieren praktisch jeden tag mit
den anderen kollegen in den uniklinika
jeder hat an seinem standort ein modell
entwickelt wie man damit umgeht mit der
derzeitigen krise und immer wieder
denken sie bei einzelnen dingen die sie
von den anderen hören das ist so clever
hätte man irgendwie auch selber drauf
kommen können
oder eigentlich drauf kommen müssen und
von daher ist der aktive austausch
dieser geschichte von ganz enormer
bedeutung
wir haben dann eben eine unterstützung
eines flächendeckenden ausbaus sehr
intensiv medizin
wir schaffen entsprechende
datengrundlagen hatte die ministerin
schon gesagt die ganz enorm wichtig sind
wir verstehen heute nicht wirklich warum
einzelne patienten auch jüngere so
empfindlich auf diese diesem virus
reagieren und glauben dass wir
individuelle sensibilitäten viel besser
verstehen können in zukunft eher droste
darauf eingehen dass das ganze grundlage
für eine gezielte impf wirkstoff
entwicklung ist und natürlich wollen wir
uns verknüpfen mit den umgebenden
häusern maximalversorgung berlin gibt es
einen zweiten großen maximalversorger
vivantes mit denen wir sehr eng
zusammenarbeiten und wir denken auch
darüber nach wie wir versorgung in der
häuslichkeit strukturell verbessern
können wir wollen unbedingt die testung
weiterentwickeln
deutschland steht deswegen das wird der
osten gleich noch erklären
relativ gut da im vergleich zu anderen
ländern jedenfalls im moment weil wir
früher angefangen haben zu testen und
deswegen diese ganze epidemie relativ
früh charakterisieren konnten
dabei spielt eine sache eine besondere
rolle die vielleicht noch nicht so zu
ihnen gedrungen ist für uns ist
essenziell dass wir einen ständigen
überblick über unsere eigene workforce
haben das heißt wir müssen unbedingt
wissen wie sich eigentlich das pandemie
verhalten im krankenhaus bei unseren
eigenen arbeitskräften weil dafür
brauchen wir ein ausbau dieser test
fähigkeit und wollen das gerne in dem
diversifizierten deutschen
forschungssystem mit den anderen
stakeholdern zusammen machen
es gibt klare hinweise darauf
beziehungsweise ansagen das helmholtz
fraunhofer leibnitz und auch die
deutschen zentren für
gesundheitsforschung an dieser
initiative mitarbeiten werden dass wir
also vielleicht zum ersten mal in
deutschland
die kräfte in der biomedizin hinter ein
thema bekommen und das ist sicher im
moment nicht das zentrale thema wenn das
alles mal vorbei ist sollten wir uns
auch darüber gedanken machen wie wir
eigentlich das gesundheitssystem der
zukunft aufstellen müssen um in zukunft
für solche dinge besser gerüstet zu sein
also etwa verhalte kapazitäten
reservekapazitäten vorzuhalten
zusammenfassend ich würde gerne sagen
dass dieses programm von einem großen
zutrauen an die universitätsmedizin von
seiten des hauses zeigt und von der von
der überzeugung dass man hier gemeinsam
wirklich was erreichen kann wir nehmen
das als eine verpflichtung an und wollen
in kurzer zeit erhebliche fortschritte
erreichen der das haus hier die
mitarbeiter projektträger haben ein
programm in kürzester zeit aufgesetzt
entschieden
mit einer beeindruckenden bisher noch
nie dagewesenen geschwindigkeit und
intensität und das haus die ministerin
demonstrieren handlungsfähigkeit und
entschlossenheit
ich fasse das mal zusammen auch wenn man
schon lange in dieser szene tätig ist so
etwas wie dieses programm das der staat
auf eine ressource in einer notsituation
wirklich gezielt zurückgreift so ein
programm hat es in deutschland in der
forschung noch nie gegeben
das ministerium setzt hier auf die
unimedizin und zwar im sinne von
kooperationen statt kompositionen die
sonst zwischen uns üblich ist und
patientenversorgung und forschung gehen
hier hand in hand in der bekämpfung
dieser aktuellen krise vielen dank
danke dass ich hier auch zu wort kommen
darf ich spreche vielleicht für viele
wissenschaftler die an
universitätskliniken tätig sind und
jetzt in diesen tagen merken wie nahe
das problem eigentlich kommt wir müssen
vielleicht dieses neue thema uns mal
reflektieren
wir sind einerseits
der sowohl versorgung als auch der
forschung bei den uni kliniken
eigentlich da wo das ganze passiert
verteilt in ganz deutschland wo die
situation zum teil ganz unterschiedlich
sind und wo wir dann aber auch eben
aufnahmefähig sind für die entwicklungen
um die klum uniklinik herum
ein beispiel der grund warum wir in
deutschland und das fragen journalisten
aus ganzer welt ich könnte könnte ihn so
viele anfragen zeigen in meinem e mail
eingang der grund warum wir in
deutschland im moment so wenige
todesfälle haben gegenüber der zahl der
infizierten ist hinreichend damit zu
erklären dass wir extrem viel
labordiagnostik machen in deutschland
schätzungen die jetzt in diesen letzten
tagen rein kommen lassen vermuten dass
wir im bereich von einer halben million
pcr-test jede woche durchführen in
deutschland über die fläche verteilt
wir müssen das schätzen das hört sich an
wie eine schwäche dass wir das nicht
genau wissen
wir müssen das deswegen schätzen weil
wir eine ganz große stärke bei uns im
land haben das ist dass der gesamte
labormedizin bereich und das getrieben
von den uni kliniken jeweils noch eine
sehr große nähe zum handwerk hat dh
labormediziner in ganz deutschland
können noch selbst solche tester
aufbauen wenn ihnen jemand ein rezept
dafür gibt und das rezept kam schon im
januar von der charité und wurde gleich
im kollegenkreis bei allen
universitätskliniken verteilt und das
hatte extreme umgebung sekte die uni
kliniken konnten innerhalb von ganz
kurzer zeit schon lange vor ende januar
diese diagnostik durchführen und es ist
dann immer regional so ich weiß das ganz
genau ich habe vor der charité zehn
jahre eine universitätsklinikum bonn
denselben job gemacht
diese lokalität die ist wichtig die
niedergelassenen labore in der umgebung
die krankenhaus labore in der umgebung
aber auch die klinischen abteilungen in
der umgebung profitieren unmittelbar
davon dass da ein regionaler leuchtturm
ist eine uniklinik die ein oder zwei
schritte voraus ist aus einem netzwerk
der kollegialität in der universitäts
mit
und das steht an der grenze zwischen
forschung ein neuer test wird etabliert
und ausgerollt und der direkten
patientenbehandlung und dieser effekt
den gibt es auch in der wissenschafts
namen patientenbehandlung also einfach
die frage wie macht ihr das eigentlich
mit dieser krankheit mit diesen
patienten die wir noch nicht kennen
diese frage wird an allen stellen in
deutschland im moment gestellt und zwar
jeweils vom großen stadtkrankenhaus oder
kreiskrankenhaus an die lokale uniklinik
und warum ist das so weil man sich kennt
denn die chefärzte an diesen
kreiskrankenhäusern sind ja häufig die
ehemaligen ober ärzte an der uniklinik
so funktioniert das in kollegialen
netzwerken und da gibt es fließende
übergang übergänge zwischen versorgung
und forschung wir haben das in solchen
forschungsnahen feldern wie der
mikrobiologie und labormedizin genauso
mit den niedergelassenen laboren und
diese nähe zum problem diese nähe zur
region und die nähe ja dann wieder eben
doch zu der spitze der forschung und zu
der spitze der versorgung
das ist es was wirklich einen
unterschied macht und da reicht die
universitätsmedizin eben in jede
verzweigung der lokalen netzwerke hinein
und ein anderer grund warum ich glaube
dass es ganz wichtig ist dass jetzt in
dieser situation die universitätsmedizin
den ton angibt in der forschung ist die
nähe zum problem zum patienten wir die
universitätskliniken und die forscher an
den universitätskliniken haben die nähe
zu den krankenhausbetten und haben das
problem vor der tür und bei uns klingeln
die telefone von der station es ist
jeden tag so dass ich mit behandlern
sprecherin der charité und in anderen
krankenhäusern
obwohl ich selber natürlich nicht im
krankenhaus arbeiten ich bin ja virologe
aber ein virologe an der
universitätsmedizin ist natürlich viel
näher dran am eigentlichen problem als
ein biologe in einem forschungsinstitut
das sich eher mit theoretischen aspekten
beschäftigt wir beschäftigen uns auch
mit theoretischen aspekten häufig gibt
es aber dann sogar in form
instituten spezialisten die das besser
können als wir und da sind wir wieder
als forscher an den universitätskliniken
genau die vermittler zwischen den ober
spezialisten an den vielleicht etwas
weit entfernten forschungsinstituten an
den großforschungseinrichtungen und den
versorgenden infektionsmediziner die den
patienten sehen
da machen wir die verbindung und
erreichen wir die erkenntnisse weiter
manchmal reichen wir die tabletten
weiter im wahrsten sinne des wortes wir
haben im moment eine situation in der
wir einen ungewöhnlichen pragmatismus
brauchen wir sind hier in einer phase
von draco racing das heißt wir wollen
möglichst sofort verfügbare medikamente
ausprobieren in ihrer wirkung für diese
neue erkrankung wir müssen zeit gewinnen
durch diese pragmatische maßnahme und da
brauchen wir leute die an den grundlagen
arbeiten und sagen diese substanz könnte
wirken dann brauchen wir insbesondere
solche vermittler wie die
wissenschaftler in der
universitätsmedizin und dann brauchen
wir die kliniker die diesen
wissenschaftlern im eigenen haus
vertrauen und mit diesen
wissenschaftlern gemeinsam klinische
studien aufbauen weil man miteinander
sprechen kann und weil man sagt das ist
so ein guter experte hier bei uns im
haus in unserer virologie dem vertraue
ich und darum brauche ich eine patientin
courage auf für dieses neue medikament
das noch niemand ausprobiert hat gegen
diese neue erkrankung
wir haben keine andere rettung aus der
jetzigen situation als dass wir solche
pragmatische forschung machen und damit
meine ich pragmatische klinische
forschung
dafür braucht es die steuerung und die
verantwortung in diesen kollegialen
netzwerken zwischen wissenschaft und
praxis und gleichzeitig und das will ich
auch noch sagen hat das ganze natürlich
ganz natürliche koordinations effekte
also es ist jetzt nicht so wie es sonst
häufig in der forschungsförderung ist
das ein großes geldvolumen ausgelobt
wird für bewerbungen darauf und
verschiedene zum teil auch
abenteuerliche ideen miteinander
konkurrieren
und natürlich auch dinge gemacht werden
die zwar auch wissenschaftlich sinnvoll
sind aber die eigentliche
an der grundlage bleiben wir haben hier
dadurch dass wir aus der
universitätsmedizin heraus agieren und
das hoffen wir uns erhoffen wir uns alle
aus dieser maßnahme einen ganz
natürlichen steuerungs effekt der durch
die nähe zu den patienten kommt und die
wahrnehmung die wir aus der nähe zum
patienten haben und auch bei der
betrachtung der fallzahlen ist ganz
einfach dass wir aus dieser situation
nur herauskommen wenn wir letztendlich
entweder in breiter fläche behandeln
können oder wenn wir impfen können
die impfung ist natürlich das
eigentliche ziel aber es ist leider auch
ein schwer zu erreichendes ziel wir
müssen im moment da auch zeit
überbrücken
in diesem sinne glaube ich dass dieses
forschungsnetzwerk jetzt einen weg
aufzeigt wie man in solchen situationen
besser mit der gesamtsituation umgehen
kann wie man direkt aus der forschung
heraus die patientenversorgung und damit
das überleben von infizierten patienten
direkt sichern kann und wie wir damit
aber auch natürlich auf lange sicht ein
neues denk und handlungsmuster schaffen
für die koordination und die ausrichtung
von klingt klinik nahe
infektionsforschung auf den patienten
herzlichen dank wir kommen jetzt zu
ihren fragen ich würde vorschlagen dass
wir vielleicht versuchen erst einen den
ersten fragenkomplex dass wir uns damit
beschäftigen was dieses projekt angeht
und dann kommen wir liegen wir auch
schon fragen vor die jetzt zur
entwicklung der pandemie hier insgesamt
gestellt werden vielleicht können wir
das versuchen so etwas zu gliedern es
ist etwas einfacher
ich will gehen vielleicht mal mit einer
frage die uns der kollege jörg ratzsch
von dpa gestellt hat die geht an sie
herr professor krömer eine solche
initiative verkündet man wahrscheinlich
nicht schreibt er ohne vorher mit
anderen kliniken gesprochen zu haben wie
groß ist denn die bereitschaft aus ihrer
sicht der anderen universitätskliniken
bei dieser bei diesen forschungsnetzwerk
mitzumachen
also ich denke aus dem was christian
drosten hier gerade geschildert hat
sind alle universitätskliniken in
deutschland heute in einer ähnlichen
situation auch jeder entwickelt
individuelle maßnahmen und pläne um mit
dieser situation umzugehen und es gibt
einen ganz hohen bedarf sich
untereinander auszutauschen
aber das ist die eine seite das betrifft
sowohl die versorgung seite als auch die
forschung seite wo man in
unterschiedlichen schwerpunkten
kooperativ zusammenarbeiten kann und ich
würde gerne noch auf einen anderen punkt
aufmerksam machen
im moment sieht es ja so aus als wenn
unterschiedliche teile von deutschland
mit einer unterschiedlichen intensität
betroffen sind
das heißt auch die nachfrage nach
behandlungsmöglichkeiten ist
möglicherweise so regional
unterschiedlich dass man sich in einem
geografisch überschaubaren land wie
deutschland auch gegenseitig helfen kann
auch dass es ein aspekt der möglichen
gegenseitigen hilfe zwischen den
bundesländern bei freunden kapazitäten
den ich mir von diesem programm er hoffe
und es gibt ein großes interesse von
seiten der kollegen mit denen man
natürlich vor darüber gesprochen haben
sich in dieses netzwerk zu begeben die
frage von frau zinkant von der
süddeutschen zeitung gestellt wie viel
geld gibt es für das bündnis aber vor
allen dingen wie wird es verteilt und an
wen konkret ministerin
also wir geben jetzt 150 millionen in
diesem jahr 100 millionen im nächsten
jahr 50 millionen
das projekt ist ja erstmal jetzt auf die
nächsten anderthalb bis zwei jahre
ausgelegt damit wir eben dieses netzwerk
schaffen können dass eine intensive
zusammenarbeit zwischen den
universitätskliniken stattfinden kann
ich glaube professor krömer hat eben
sehr schön gesagt wir müssen jetzt dafür
sorgen dass systeme geschaffen werden wo
man sich die guten ideen auf sehr kurzen
wegen im grunde teilt also diese
information sharing ist eigentlich das
was der kern ist um jetzt gerade auch in
der behandlung von patienten und in dem
was man vielleicht auch zum teil mal
ausprobiert was wirkt denn um patienten
zu helfen dass das eben möglichst sich
auch ganz schnell verbreitet in
deutschland und deswegen also wir sagen
wir stärken dieses netzwerk dadurch dass
wir eben die netzwerkbildung finanzieren
deswegen kann man nicht sagen wo gibt es
genau hin sondern wo gebraucht wo geld
gebraucht wird um dieses netzwerk
möglichst schnell aufzubauen da geht das
geld auch hin
ein punkt der mir wirklich noch wichtig
ist das wir anstreben
dieses netzwerk auch auszuweiten und
stück auf die außeruniversitären
forschungseinrichtungen oder sie in
deutschland in den letzten jahren ja
sehr sehr viel getan aber das haus hat
die deutschen zentren für gesundheit
aufgebaut die ein großes interesse daran
geäußert haben sich mit diesem netzwerk
hier zu verbinden
gleiches gilt für fraunhofer oder für
die helmholtz-gemeinschaft und alle
diese einrichtungen haben
unterschiedliche expertise in
unterschiedlichen bereichen die aus
meiner sicht durchaus aktiv sein kann so
dass es vielleicht gelingt in diesem
fall dass etwas diversifizierte deutsche
forschungssystem hinter einer
fragestellung letztendlich zu vereinen
ich denke dass wir mal zu den fragen
hier im auditorium kommen die dame
linksaußen bitte
können wir vielleicht das mikro haben
wir ein mikro was wir weiterreichen
können
die für die hörer im livestream ja ja es
gibt ja im moment wird in den medien
auch in der politik teilweise eine
debatte geführt über eine mögliche exit
strategie und aus der situation in der
wir jetzt sind und auch über die frage
ob es nicht jetzt sinnvoll wäre wo das
virus schon so weit verbreitet ist die
risikogruppen zu isolieren und die
anderen im grunde wieder raus zu lassen
wie sehen sie das und was wäre ein
zeitraum in dem so was vorstellbar wäre
solche einfachen vorstellungen dass man
nur die risikogruppen isoliert die
funktionieren nicht
das ist trivial das kann man dann hat es
schon modell modellrechnungen dafür
gegeben und da ist man sehr weit davon
entfernt dass man irgendeinen effekt
erwarten könnte aber sie stellen die
frage natürlich genau in die richtige
richtung
das ist eine frage nach der
differenzierung der maßnahmen also wie
kommt man jetzt in der vergangenheit in
der zukunft weiter indem man sagt
natürlich muss man daraus das ist ja
vollkommen klar
aber an welcher stelle kommt man als
erstes raus und an welcher stelle bleibt
man lieber noch drin auch das ist
natürlich eine frage an die wissenschaft
es wurden jetzt politische
entscheidungen getroffen mit gutem recht
die sehr breit wirken
und jetzt muss man die wirkung wieder
etwas spezifischer machen und die frage
die sich an die wissenschaft hier
richtet ist die frage nach den
vorhersagbaren effekten und
modellierungs wissenschaft will genau
das beantworten also wir wollen
natürlich wissen wenn wir die
biologische modellannahmen füttern mit
speziellen daten über deutschland
vielleicht sogar regionalen daten in
teilen von deutschland wie ist die
situation jetzt wie ist die demographie
wie sind bestimmte andere faktoren
wie ist aber auch die weiterentwicklung
der epidemie also wie viele personen
sind jetzt schon immun und wie viele
werden in einem monat immun seien alle
diese dinge bringen dann natürlich eine
viel feinere auflösung in solche modelle
vorhersagen und diese modelle
vorhersagen braucht jetzt die politik um
dann adjustierungen zu machen für die
einmal getroffenen entscheidungen das
war glaube ich von vornherein der plan
und dem plan wird man jetzt auch folgen
und zwar in nächster zeit professor
grünen nur ganz kurz darauf hinweisen
sie haben wahrscheinlich wahrgenommen
das letzte woche sich die nationale
wissenschaftsakademie geäußert hatte zu
der gesamt pandemie und auch empfehlung
ausgesprochen hatte und die haben jetzt
in der folge genau zu der frage die sie
gestellt haben
entsprechend der arbeitsgruppen
aufgestellt das heißt es ist davon
auszugehen dass auch wieder aus dieser
organisation innerhalb der nächsten
wochen entsprechende empfehlungen
vorschläge kommen wobei glaube ich den
beiden leuten die hieraus entstehen noch
mal ganz wichtig ist zu sagen weil das
jetzt manchmal anders in der zeitung
steht das land wird hier nicht von
virologen regiert sondern die
entscheidung am ende des tages muss nach
wie vor die politik geben wir können mit
unseren organisationen nur eine
grundlage geben oder entscheidungs
vielleicht horizont aufspannen aber die
endgültigen entscheidungen die müssen
eindeutig politisch getroffen
mit ein paar sätzen ergänzen
das ist aber genau der punkt dass
während das ist natürlich verschiedene
szenarien gibt die funktionieren das ist
ja das eine epidemiologische frage
das nächste ist auch eine frage und
unter soziologischen gesichtspunkten wie
geht eine gesellschaft überhaupt damit
um diese ersten tage sind ja relativ
einfach also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
ich bin total stolz darauf wie
diszipliniert im grunde sich alle an die
regeln halten und dass das so gut
funktioniert ist eben keine
selbstverständlichkeit und eben auch
kein dauerzustand
und deswegen muss man unter sehen bin
ich so froh dass da die leopoldina jetzt
auch mit im boot ist mit ihren
als gruppen die das aus den ganz
verschiedenen perspektiven heraus
beleuchtet und am ende ist genau das da
werden im grunde entscheidungsgrundlagen
für uns gelegt auf die wir uns dann auch
stützen können und wo wir natürlich
diese verschiedenen möglichkeiten wie
kommen wir wieder in einen normalzustand
in deutschland zurück wo wir dann uns
ganz genau über diese verschiedenen
mechanismen gedanken machen müssen
und das tun wir in enger abstimmung mit
der wissenschaft aber wer professor
krömer das gesagt ist das eine wir
brauchen solide grundlagen was gibt es
für alternativen um im grunde wieder
zurückzukommen in ein normales
miteinander ohne eben unsere kapazitäten
in der gesundheitswirtschaft zu
überfordern
aber eben auch immer unter der
perspektive was bedeutet das für unsere
gesellschaft wäre es am wehr ist zum
beispiel auch ich sag mal am meisten
gefährdet das wissen weil die älteren
was kann man aber auch gerade den
älteren an dieser stelle zumuten wie
geht man mit denen mit den gruppen der
jungen um es gibt ganz viele
unterschiedliche fragen in dem bereich
und deswegen bin ich so froh dass ich
jetzt arbeitsgruppen auch aus
verschiedenen perspektiven damit
beschäftigen uns diese grundlage zu
erarbeiten die wir dann diskutieren
müssen und dann die entscheidungen
treffen müssen wir machen was denn in
der praxis nach dem sogenannten
ausstiegsszenario von verschiedenen
anderen kollegen gestellt worden sind
die wir dann damit hiermit auch
beantwortet haben frau gehen mal wer die
nächste vorgestellt zwei fragen herr
professor krömer sie haben gesagt man
telefoniert mit den anderen und stellten
fest klasse idee hätte man auch drauf
kommen können haben sie da mal ein zwei
beispiele und an herrn professor drosten
sie haben letzte woche war es glaube ich
sie haben vorgeschlagen im podcast dass
man die regularien die bisher gelten
doch auf eine gewisse art und weise
außer kraft setzen soll also die ganze
das ganz normale prozedere mit drei
klinischen phasen der prüfung et cetera
für medikamente beziehungsweise
impfstoffe und haben vorgeschlagen auf
diesem weg ich fass es jetzt ganz plump
zusammen besser kann ich nicht ein altes
medikament was schon teilweise
getestet wurde einfach anzuwenden also
wo sind wir wird sowas schon gemacht wer
entscheidet das wann wird das
entschieden und wenn wir es schon machen
wer macht das und wo und wofür also ich
muss sagen dass ich jetzt ein paar
sachen die sie da jetzt von mir zitieren
lange nachdenken muss um mich daran zu
erinnern
also an etwas mit einem alten saß
medikament kann ich mich tatsächlich
nicht erinnern
es ist aber natürlich so und das habe
ich nicht vorgeschlagen sondern das
wurde in einem hintergrund- gespräch mit
wissenschaftsjournalisten einfach mal
erörtert das ist ja bestimmte
zulassungskriterien gibt sowohl für
medikamente als auch für impfstoffe und
ich glaube wir haben da vor allem über
impfstoffe gesprochen weil das problem
dort brennend ist wo man einfach sich
schon die frage stellen muss wie hoch
ist eigentlich die sicherheit die man
braucht für einen impfstoff den man
speziell jetzt in der ersten zeit also
als allererstes vielleicht anwenden
wollte für eine risikogruppe die ein
sehr hohes risiko eben durch die
eigentliche infektion ist erfährt und da
ist es dann eine sache der
zulassungsbehörden drauf zu schauen und
zu schauen wie die risiko überlegung in
anbetracht der situation ist das
bedeutet nicht dass man dinge außer
kraft setzt sondern dass man dinge
anders behandelt und möglichst aber auch
auf wissen zurückgreifen das schon
besteht oder auf vorarbeiten
zurückgreift die schon gemacht worden
sind
in der vakzine entwicklung gibt es das
beispiel dass man bestimmte zugelassene
vakzine vektoren um nutzt für einen
neuen krankheitserreger und dann den
vorteil ausnutzt das man im prinzip
dieses vector system das trägersystem
für einen impfstoff schon gut kennt und
nur noch modifizieren muss und dabei
kann man natürlich zeit gewinnen in
zulassungsprozesse weil man nicht vor
einer vollkommen unbekannten situation
steht
das will ich mal sagen ist umgesetzte
praxis schon längst in deutschland wir
haben ja es geschafft in deutschland
sehr maßgeblichen beitrag für die ebola
vakzine zu leisten basierend auf diesem
prinzip
wir haben sehr große fortschritte für
einem erwachsene und es laufen gerade
ähnliche ziemlich erfolgreich
angefangene unternehmungen richtung eine
maxime für saas krone virus 2
auch kurze ihre beiden fragen
beantworten nämlich beziehungsweise die
frage was sie seien ein gutes beispiel
für umgangsformen was mich in teilen
beeindruckt hat war wie einzelne
bundesländer mit der gesamtorganisation
umgegangen sind und es geschafft haben
über ihre bundesländer hinaus und zwar
unter nutzung der universitätsmedizin
tatsächlich eine struktur und
entscheidungsstruktur über ein
bundesland hinzubekommen das finde ich
hin ist in sachsen sehr gelungen wo man
zwischen leipzig und dresden die
unimedizin für so etwas
letztendlich genutzt hat hessen ist auch
ziemlich weit in diesen organisations in
diesen organisationsformen die kann man
sich denken abgucken da kann man
voneinander lernen dann gibt es andere
probleme die wir an jedem standort haben
die wir auch ja täglich in unserem
eigenen ausnahmen ascom patienten von
außerhalb mit einer völlig anderen
indikationen auch nicht passenden
symptomatik die am ende des tages aber
doch positiv für co at 19 sind und die
möglicherweise dann erst später entdeckt
werden auch aufgrund der verzögerung der
testen und ähnliche dinge um die frage
wie halte ich eigentlich effektiv meine
eigene workforce am leben wie mache ich
das in einem so großen unternehmen
da gibt es vorschläge unter anderem von
herrn drosten dass man regelmäßig
tatsächlich seien der mitarbeiterschaft
komplett anguckt dazu solche pool
verfahren verwendet also mehrere
gleichzeitig testet wenn dann der test
negativ ist weiß man dass alle virus
frei sind wenn sie positiv sind muss man
sie einzeln testen also es gibt eine
ganze vielzahl von beispielen
wo man letztendlich sagen wir von den
anderen lernen kann und dinge die man
selber betreffen dann auch entsprechend
am eigenen standort nachmachen kann ein
team von frau h rauf da geht es auch ums
testen bislang fragt frau haus von der
tat gibt es in deutschland kein
screening ganzer bevölkerungsgruppen wir
jetzt hier nicht gerade über eine
bevölkerungsgruppe aber es passt
vielleicht wäre die test und
verschiedener kohorten von bisher nicht
getesteten personen aus ihrer sicht aus
wissenschaftlicher sicht sinnvoll um
festzustellen wie weit das virus bereits
in der bevölkerung verbreitet ist ja das
kann ich vielleicht beantworten
wir haben initiativen in ganz
deutschland die das jetzt gerade
aufbauen
das ist weniger vielleicht jetzt wie
hier auch in der frage die vorstellung
war dass man mit der
polymerase-kettenreaktion den direkten
nachweis durchführt bei irgendwelchen
zufällig zusammengewürfelten gruppen von
probanden das würde wahrscheinlich
momentan noch nicht zu allzu viel führen
nur mal von ihrer vorstellung damit sich
das auch so plastisch mal vor augen
führen können bei den testungen im
moment die ja doch sehr häufig kontakt
oder so ein symptom getrieben sind
meistens in beides ja also da ist ein
kontakt und da sind klare symptome
da machen wir sehr viele tester im
moment ich hatte vor einmal von um eine
halbe million in der woche gesprochen
und da ist die positive rate so 67
prozent und wenn sie jetzt vorstellen
dass würden sie machen bei leuten die
gar keine symptome oder keinen kontakt
haben da würden sie im moment noch nicht
viel erwarten
deswegen ist die herangehensweise
eigentlich eine andere die organisation
solcher kurorten untersuchungen braucht
vorlauf die das muss gut geplant werden
sonst ist es sinnlos sonst hat man nur
anekdotische daten und weiß hinterher
nichts dann hat man viel zeit und geld
investiert und hat keine information
wir brauchen ein paar wochen um solche
kohorten aufzubauen und wir werden sie
dann weil ein paar wochen vergangen sind
auch mit einem an
sinnvolleren test untersuchen können
nämlich mit einem antikörper test
diese antikörper test sind ebenfalls
gerade im aufbau und in der auswahlphase
erste firmen können die jetzt wirklich
produzieren und anbieten labore können
die etablieren und projekte werden jetzt
geplant und geschrieben und wir werden
natürlich in der zeit nach ostern
plötzlich sehr viele daten in diese
richtung bekommen also das ist nicht so
dass da vielleicht nicht dran gedacht
wurde sondern im gegenteil ist laufen
fieberhafte planungen aber man muss auch
genau an der richtigen stelle schauen
ich denke es kommen zwei dinge zusammen
das eine ist das was ich jetzt gerade
beschrieben habe eben solche breit
angelegten und sinnvoll gezielten
antikörper studien dass andere werden
informationen vor allem auch aus
mitarbeiter testungen sein gerade auch
aus krankenhäusern
aber vielleicht sogar über krankenhäuser
hinaus das ist aber auch der zeit etwas
das erst konzipiert wird federführend
ist dabei eindeutig die
universitätsklinik köln auch das dortige
institut für virologie hat das sehr
stark mit vorgedacht und dann auch mit
uns besprochen und wir finden das ebenso
sinnvoll und so sind viele andere
universitätskliniken auch jetzt
eigentlich entschieden das machen zu
wollen und aus dieser mitarbeiter
testung werden wir auch sehr viele
informationen heraus bekommen
vielen dank der kollege zuerst professor
drosten das thema wurde angesprochen die
medikamentenentwicklung konzertsatz dazu
sagen ihre einschätzung es gibt
verschiedene meldungen weltweit das
jetzt medikamente die auf dem markt der
sinn für andere behandlungen und
therapien auf dem das sie getestet
werden wie sehen sie die perspektiven
und die zweite frage an herrn professor
krömer
es gibt ja heute in der faz die macht
damit auf diese handreichung
in sachen triage die anstünde demnächst
in deutschen kliniken
wie schätzen sie das ein teilen sie
diese befürchtungen didaktisch
beschrieben wird und zweitens halten sie
das für sinnvoll solche handreichungen
vielen dank gut ich kann vielleicht
eingangs kurz sagen also es geht jetzt
hier in der frage und auch in der
forschung um replacing also existierende
medikamente die man nebenbei benutzen
kann vielleicht für dieses neue virus
da gibt es ja zum beispiel die meldungen
über chloroquin wo viele experten
skeptisch sind und wurde jetzt
existierenden klinischen studien noch
nicht sehr viele aussagen
ich bin ebenso auch skeptisch was diese
substanz angeht auch wenn man im
reagenzglas infekt gegen das virus sieht
das sieht man gegen viele andere wären
auch mit dieser substanz es könnte aber
ein sehr allgemeiner effekt sein denn
man vor allem an zellkultur beobachtet
ich will aber auch nicht sagen dass das
letzte wort gesprochen ist die substanz
hat auch anti inflammatorische effekte
und wir wissen nicht ganz genau wie die
situation mit der immunreaktion in der
lunge in der kritischen phase der
patienten ist und vielleicht hat es
darauf dann doch einen einfluss man
erlebt manchmal überraschungen
eine andere substanz das sind die
proteasehemmer kombination aus der hiv
therapie da gibt es eine große klinische
studie die jetzt schon veröffentlicht
wurde die nicht sehr optimistisch
aussieht aber auch da sind nicht alle
studien abgeschlossen und so können wir
das weiter durchdeklinieren es gibt zwei
mindestens substanzen die
vielversprechender sind weil wenn klaren
mechanismus kennen und die auch schon in
großen studien jetzt sind die eine hat
schon eine vorveröffentlichung und die
sieht überraschend gut aus also da habe
ich mich darüber gewundert und das ist
eine substanz aus der influenza
forschung dass jetzt endlich im stück
gerade auf dem schlauch es ist nicht
rennen die sie wir sondern wer kann es
gerade sagen
ich bin gerade im redefluss fels
mariazell grad nicht ein wenig nicht wer
das ist das proteasehemmer habib ari
pira wir fahr'n wir ja also das ist so
eine
eine substanz die kommt eigentlich aus
der influenza behandlung die es in
einigen ländern zugelassenen asien und
wir haben eigentlich früher im
reagenzglas für corona während keinen
guten effekt gesehen aber nun wird das
eben clean studiert und
erstaunlicherweise sieht man anfangs
evidenz für eine wirkung aber die ist
klein und man braucht auch noch mehr
studien um dazu etwas zu sagen und dann
gibt es noch weitere substanzen die so
eine nach der anderen jetzt auch
vorgeschlagen werden und die auch in
vielen studien eingehen das ist ja auch
genau gerade der sinn von dieser von
diesem netzwerk das hier gebildet werden
soll dass dort wo die patienten sind
eben neue studie name eröffnet werden
können was was die wirkung von rhi per
post rocks angeht also schon
zugelassener medikamente anfang märz
schon die das programm hier vorgestellt
das wo wir gesagt haben das eine ist
eben zugelassene medikamente weiter
testen ob sie wirksam sind für coop 19
neue medikamente zu entwickeln oder eben
auch die grundsätzlich das virus noch
besser zu verstehen das ist ja warum er
anfang märz schon vorgestellt und das
ist genau das was man jetzt dafür auch
nutzen kann auch gern auf ihre vorgaben
gehen weil aber das war heute wirklich
die frontseiten der zeitung dominiert
und wahrscheinlich jeder hier im raum in
den letzten tagen dieser bilder aus
italien gesehen hat und die frage sich
ein stück weit aufdrängt ich glaube hier
in deutschland haben wir ja nach wie vor
das credo jeden menschen nach den
individuellen notwendigkeiten zu
behandeln und hatten zu anfang gesagt
wie sich die charité will sich berlin
wie sich deutschland
auf diese situation vorbereitet und aus
meiner sicht gibt es immer noch eine
gute chance dass wir diesen grundsatz
auch nicht verlassen müssen
es gibt da verschiedene teilaspekte die
jetzt intensiv versucht werden wenn etwa
davon auszugehen ist dass auch
schwerkranke menschen im peripheren
krankenhäusern liegen dass man dann eine
enge anbindung an die
universitätsmedizin über telemedizin
hinbekommt das wird bei uns sehr
intensiv aus unserer anästhesiologie
betrieben in jedem fall gehe ich davon
aus dass wenn solche entscheidungen zu
treffen sind
das individuelle dann ärztliche
entscheidungen sind die in einem starken
kontrast stehen zur allgemeinen
handreichungen die sie hier und heute in
zeitungen publizieren sie können davon
ausgehen dass in den häusern nachgedacht
wird wie man mit situationen umgehen
kann
ich glaube nicht dass man da zur
handreichungen machen sollte und was mir
wirklich noch am herzen liegen würde
wenn eine solche diskussion aufkommt und
intensiviert wird ist es keine
diskussion mit der sie die ärzteschaft
alleine lassen sollten sondern dass es
eine breite gesellschaftliche diskussion
wie mit solchen fragestellungen
umzugehen ist und wie gesagt meines
erachtens eignen sie sich hier und heute
nicht dafür handreichungen zu schreiben
sie sagen das eignet sich nicht für
handreichung aber wie bereiten sie sich
denn vor weil diese frage könnte
anstehen und muss es dann nicht sagen
wir mal empfehlungen zumindest geben wie
sich dann die ärzte noch verhalten
könnten
ich glaube dass man in deutschland
zumindest noch ein bisschen zeit hat
sich damit intensiv auseinanderzusetzen
und es gibt ja ganz verschiedene
stellschrauben eine stellschraube die
wir jetzt intensiv genutzt haben die wir
geschrieben haben ist diese erhöhung der
intensiv kapazität sie werden dann in
einem nächsten schritt wahrscheinlich
schwerer als üblich kranken patienten
auch in peripheren stationen liegen
haben und können diese peripheren
station jetzt auch ein stück weit schon
darauf vorbereiten dass heißt das werden
die stellschrauben über die wir im
moment nachdenken
also wir sind weniger unterwegs jetzt
eine konkrete handreichung für einen
fall
den wir nicht wirklich antik
antizipieren können zu schreiben ich
sage immer ein praktisches beispiel sind
davon ausgegangen in unseren vorher
berechnungen dass in berlin
die zunahme der intensiv flüchtigen
patienten exponentiell erfolgt das ist
seit einer woche nicht mehr passiert das
heißt das was wir jetzt in der letzten
woche gesehen haben ist eine relative
konstanten relativ marginalen anstieg
jedenfalls bei uns im haus für intensiv
pflichtigen patienten
insofern kann es durchaus auch eine eine
denkbare situation geben spekuliere
jetzt ohne jede grundlage darüber wenn
das eine woche so weiter geht noch und
dann ein anstieg erfolgt dass der so
verzögert erfolgt dass tatsächlich die
intensiv kapazität in berlin
ausreichend ist um mit dieser epidemie
fertig zu werden so dass ich dann diese
folge fragen die sie gerade gestellt
haben und dieser form nicht stellen
das heißt wir setzen uns damit
auseinander glauben aber nicht dass es
geeignet ist da jetzt in welcher
handreichung zu publizieren dank ich
glaube wir blicken wir auf die uhr wenn
es möglich ist haben sie vielleicht noch
eine viertelstunde zeit aber auch
wirklich so zahlreiche fragen ich lese
jetzt mal wieder eine frage hier vor die
uns über per mail erreicht hat der
kollege krämer von reuters fragt denken
sie professor torsten wie schätzen sie
die entwicklung in den nächsten tagen
ein flacht die sich die kurve bei den
infektionszahlen ab na ja also ich denke
was wir im moment sehen in der
statistischen entwicklung sind die
effekte von vor zwei wochen nun also
dass das war ja so dass wir vorletzte
woche vorige woche knappe zwei wochen
begonnen haben
mit maßnahmen und die haben dann noch so
ein zwei tage vorlauf gehabt also
eigentlich so seit einer guten woche
gibt es weniger kontakte und es gibt in
den letzten tagen wenn ich das richtig
erinnere ich habe heute morgen noch
keine zahlen angeschaut
ich will mal sagen eine relative
konstanz schon das ist aber noch nicht
so dass man sagen kann das ist
befund da muss man jetzt einfach noch
ein paar tage abwarten ob sich das so
zeigt dass wir tatsächlich nicht also es
geht nicht darum zu sagen es gibt keine
neuen fälle mehr sein es geht darum was
wir jetzt erwarten dass der trend dass
jeden tag die zunahme von fällen größer
ist als am tag vorher dass dieser trend
zunächst mal gebrochen wird darauf kann
man jetzt erst mal hoffen
leider ist es im moment auch so dass man
überhaupt nicht darauf hoffen kann dass
die todeszahlen gleich runter gehen denn
da gibt es eine längere verzögerung und
dann muss man sich natürlich auch klar
machen dass die maßnahmen ja auch
schrittweise eingeführt wurden und auch
jetzt schrittweise eingeübt werden wir
haben ja keine sagen wir mal komplette
kontaktsperre oder ausgangssperre
sondern wir haben im prinzip eine
begrenzung der zahl der personen die in
der öffentlichkeit sich treffen und alle
diese dinge müssen ja in der bevölkerung
auch eingeübt werden und deswegen wird
es nicht so sein dass da plötzlich wie
mit dem lineal gezogen eine änderung
auftritt aber wir können schon in den
nächsten tagen die neue meldungen
verfolgen und hoffen dass bestimmte
trends sich zunächst mal abmildern und
dann vielleicht auch einstellen
dann komme jetzt mal zu einer frage hier
aus dem auditorium
erst mal eine frage an die ministerin
mit 19 ist ein internationales problem
wie wollen sie sicherstellen dass ihre
initiative jetzt nicht das rad in
deutschland neu erfindet gibt's da
internationale vernetzung und herren
posten oder herr krömer ist sie haben
schon über die die casemod alle trades
in deutschland gesprochen und das ist
teilweise mit dem mit dem hohen tests
volumen zusammenhängt es gibt auch in
anderen ländern österreich australien
kanada ähnliche raten sehen sie dass da
auch gibt es da schon
vergleichsuntersuchungen und weil sie
ein experte für tests sind herr droste
diese die die firma bosch hat heute
einen neuen test vorgestellt
er soll innerhalb von zweieinhalb
stunden resultat bieten zudem sind 95
prozent sicherheit ausreichend
vielleicht fange ich damit an dass wir
in die welt hinein sehr sehr gut
vernetzt sind
das eine ist ja über die whu in der für
uns das bmg sitzt aber für den
forschungs teil natürlich wie auch das
zweite ist ja über das cp netzwerk was
auch über ländergrenzen hinweg agiert
und ja auch sehr stark agiert wir haben
nicht umsonst jetzt noch mal auf unsere
finanzierung für das cpi stark erhöht
wir haben noch gar nicht so lange her
noch mal 140 millionen zusätzlich allein
für dieses jahr nachgeschossen damit
eben auch noch mehr forschungs linien
für den bereich der impfstoffe
aufgemacht werden können
und all das was wir tun tun wir immer in
dem sinne erkenntnisfortschritt für
bestmögliche behandlung für
schnellstmöglichen fortschritt was wirkt
und was wirkt nicht zum beispiel auch
bei zugelassenen medikamenten schon
generieren zu können aber immer auch mit
der perspektive das wissen was wir haben
der welt zur verfügung zu stellen um
alle möglichen konsequenzen auch überall
abzumildern und nicht nur bei uns also
die idee ist uns so gut es geht
aufzustellen und für uns natürlich auch
so schnell wie möglich
forschungserkenntnisse zu haben aber sie
dann auch genauso schnell mit 1
dann zu teilen wir haben ein großes
interesse daran dass wir mit dem coup 19
in der welt schnell fertig werden es ist
ein globales problem und wir können auch
nur gemeinsam global dieses problem
lösen
ja also sie hatten zunächst mal gefragt
andere länder australien kanada hätten
eine ähnliche zahlen ich weiß nicht von
welchen zahlen sie sprechen ich weiß
nicht wie da die test häufigkeiten sind
wenn sie zahlen haben können wir diese
sprechen ja ich weiß nicht wie in diesen
ländern die fälle gezählt werden aber
das lässt vermuten dass es ähnlich ist
wie bei uns und das sind auch länder von
denen ich ganz grundsätzlich weiß dass
die natürlich im biotech bereich weit
entwickelt sind und auch sehr gezielt
testen
das kann ich mir schon vorstellen dass
das ein ähnlicher effekt ist den test
von bosch kenne ich nicht
ich weiß auch nicht auf welche 95% sich
das bezieht
es ist aber schon so dass jetzt im
moment von verschiedenen firmen pcr
geräte angeboten werden die man im
prinzip auf die station stellen kann
oder in einer ambulanz die haben aber
leider nur einen geringen durchsatz also
mit denen kann man nicht hunderte von
proben am tag testen und die reagenzien
für diese geräte sind zum teil nicht
nicht so in großer menge lieferbar so
dass wir uns sicherlich in nächster
zukunft auf das normale labor basierte
verfahren verlassen müssen
könnten sie noch einmal schildern sie
haben es gesagt für die charité man ist
da gut vorbereitet wie das
deutschlandweit aussieht also wir haben
derzeit glaube ich rund 1000 menschen in
intensivbehandlung von der kapazität und
von dem was man erwartet wie sich das
entwickeln könnte das ist glaube ich für
ganz deutschland relativ schwer zu sagen
da man offensichtlich
wenn sie auch die karten gucken ja sehr
unterschiedliche instanzen in den
einzelnen regionen hat es wird jeden tag
publiziert die fälle und auch die die
todesraten in den einzelnen
bundesländern und die die sind ja
anteilsmäßig nicht bevölkerungs
proportional direkt verteilt es gibt
einzelne einzelne hot spots wo man auch
nicht immer im detail versteht wie warum
sich gerade in einem bestimmten bereich
so etwas entwickelt
bayern nimmt man an ist mit einer hohen
skifahrer populationen geschlagen
gewesen die das ganze eben aus
österreich und italien mitgebracht haben
und dieser punkt dieser heterogenen
entwicklung in deutschland führt mich
auch nochmal zu den punkt der
möglichkeit innerhalb eines solchen
netzwerks sich auch vielleicht kapazitiv
gegenseitig zu helfen wenn das so
weitergeht und wir tatsächlich eine sehr
unterschiedliche belastung einzelner
bundesländer in deutschland haben wollte
es aus meiner sicht ziemlich naheliegend
dass man sich ja auch gegenseitig hilft
die charité hat jetzt sehr aktuell
angeboten auch an einem zugegebenermaßen
überschaubaren ausmaß sich für
italienische patienten zu engagieren als
ein symbol europäischer solidarität aber
wenn sie dann sowas denken ließ
natürlich auch sehr nahe dass man so
etwas innerhalb von deutschland macht
und davon ein enges netzwerk genutzt
ich glaube noch mal eine frage jetzt
hier aus die von außen uns erreicht hat
verlesen trebes von der rheinischen post
fragt doch mal zum impfstoff erst mal an
sie frau ministerin halten sie an ihrer
prognose fest im sommer spielt es im
herbst das dann mit klinischen studien
für einen impfstoff gestartet werden
kann und was sagen sie dazu herr
professor posten fragte triebes sich
kann man sagen wir tun alles dafür wenn
es irgendwo möglichkeiten gibt noch
prozesse zu beschleunigen dass wir sie
beschleunigen
aber und das will ich an dieser stelle
auch sagen die impfstoffforschung ist
etwas wo es eben nicht nur um
wirksamkeit geht sondern auch immer um
sicherheit und deswegen ist es glaube
ich verteile mir eine hoffnung erwecken
wenn nicht halten können denn daran
halten sich im moment ganz ganz viele
menschen fest
und ich kann das immer nur wiederholen
wir tun alles dafür wo wir unter
demokratischen gesichtspunkten unter
genehmigungs gesichtspunkten die die
prozesse beschleunigen können
aber impfstoffforschung braucht seine
zeit und deswegen bin ich da immer sehr
zurückhaltend prognosen abzugeben
ja ich könnte vielleicht auch noch sagen
es gibt ja pressemitteilungen zu dem
thema die sagen bis zum herbst gibt es
den zugelassenen impfstoff es mag sein
dass mit einigen techniken sehr schnelle
zulassungsstudien möglich sind
allerdings muss man natürlich sich auch
klarmachen dass ein impfstoff ja auch in
großer menge produziert und verkauft
werden muss und auch das ist ja eine
große herausforderung ist nützt ja am
ende wenig wenn man zugelassenen
impfstoff hat aber der ist dann nicht
für ganz deutschland verfügbar also an
diese dinge muss man schon auch denken
nicht nur an die regulativen dinge wenn
es um einen impfstoff geht
und deswegen ist es eben umso wichtiger
dass wir die zeit bis dahin überbrücken
auch mit so einem netzwerk um das es
hier heute geht mit pragmatischen dingen
also handlungsanweisungen in der
behandlung und dann jetzt das aktuelle
thema klinische studien zu bestimmten
behandlungs modalitäten dazu gehört die
um verwendung die umwidmung von
zugelassenen medikamenten aber auch der
gezielte einsatz von modifizieren und
medikamenten für das immunsystem in der
kritischen krankheitsphase darüber haben
wir jetzt noch nicht so viel gesprochen
aber auch das steht natürlich auf dem
klinischen studienprogramm und dann aber
auch praktische dinge in der intensiv
medizin die erarbeitet werden müssen in
form von richtlinien für diese spezielle
erkrankung frau eske von bloomberg news
fragt wie bewerten sie die genauigkeit
sowie den nutzen der serologischen tests
die schon erhältlich sind und wann
werden die in deutschland umfassend
genutzt werden könnte ein weniger
genauer test trotzdem von wert sein um
die dunkelziffer durch massenhafter an
anwendung zu zu berechnen oder
dunkelziffer der erkrankungen die
kollegen sicher es ist so dass wir im
moment ja gerade erst daten darüber
haben wie große labor basierte
testverfahren also elisa teste die auf
automatisierten geräten laufen können
wie die sich verhalten zur tatsächlich
nachweisbaren antikörperentwicklung und
das sieht vorsichtig optimistisch gut
aus dass da hilft uns die erkrankung
auch weil das eine akute erkrankung ist
bei erwachsenen die das zum ersten mal
im leben bekommen und deswegen nach
einiger zeit auch deutliche antikörper
haben und dann kann ich wenig sagen zu
den diesen schnellen streichen testen
die jetzt auf den markt kommen die zum
teil jetzt schon zum verkauf angeboten
werden
die sind noch gar nicht validiert die
versuchen das selbe nachzuweisen nämlich
antikörper ich will aber auch nicht
sagen dass die keine chance haben dass
die schlecht sind wir wissen es einfach
nicht man kann schon sagen dass bei
anderen infektionserkrankungen wo auch
in letzten jahren mehr solche streifen
tester entwickelt wurden die firmen die
das machen viel erfahrung gewonnen haben
und dass es durchaus gut sein kann dass
die am ende ganz gut funktionieren aber
wir müssen das einfach ausprobieren im
labor fragen und zwar fragt nochmal frau
ziehen könnt jetzt speziell nochmal zu
den auswirkungen des forschungsverbunds
also sie hatten ja gesagt adjustierungen
heißt das dass die daten aus dem
forschungsverbund die grundlage für aus
die adjustierung liefern sollen oder
werden die justierung schon jetzt
geplante reduzierung hatten sie gesagt
hat rost
also ich gehe davon aus dass
adjustierung geplant werden und zwar in
der politik ja das ist ja ganz klar bei
diesem forschungsverbund kommen wir
wahrscheinlich nicht so schnell jetzt
ans arbeiten das direkt daten aus diesem
forschungsverbund entstehen es sei denn
man sagt das sind daten aus einem
sowieso schon informell bestehenden
zusammenarbeit verhältnis zwischen
vielen universi
herzkliniken und außeruniversitären aber
die wissenschaft ist nicht nur ein
forschungsverbund von
universitätskliniken auch die
wissenschaft die vom bmbf gefördert wird
gibt durchaus sehr weit darüber hinaus
und es ist natürlich so dass sowohl
professionelle verbünde jetzt auch
gerade so im bereich von epidemiologie
aber ich würde denken auch in den
wirtschaftswissenschaften wo ich mich
gar nicht auskenne sich intensiv mit
diesem gesamtgesellschaftlichen problem
dieser pandemie beschäftigen
und ich erwarte dass wir aus all diesen
hintergründen in den nächsten wochen
daten bekommen die dann die politik
wieder nehmen kann zur basis von
entscheidungen fielen dann die
abschließende frage die ich jetzt
verlieren wir kommen von herrn
ronzheimer der fragt nochmal nach dem
leopoldina vorschlägen und welche das
bmbf als erster aufgreifen würde aber
vielleicht können sie das noch mal näher
erläutern frau ministerin
also die idee hinter den arbeitsgruppen
ist ja dass man sich aus verschiedenen
perspektiven jetzt darüber im klaren mit
was gibt es für möglichkeiten oder was
gibt es für handlungsalternativen wieder
in einen normalen modus in deutschland
zurückzukommen und was für punkte müssen
wir dabei zwingend beachten sondern dass
es eben die aufgabe der leopoldina die
jetzt daran arbeitet im grunde
entscheidungs vorschläge oder
entscheidungsgrundlagen im grunde für
uns zu erarbeiten
aus den verschiedenen perspektiven ich
hab das eben gesagt das eine ist die
epidemiologische frage dass wir im
grunde die beherrschbarkeit weil wir
haben keinen impfstoff wir müssen also
dauerhaft die beherrschbarkeit mit
unseren kapazitäten sicherstellen
und das zweite ist eben zugucken wie
wirkt das eigentlich auf die
gesellschaft was wir der gesellschaft
gerade zumuten dass es natürlich auch
unter verschiedenen gesichtspunkten noch
mal eine spannende frage was macht das
unter soziologischen gesichtspunkten mit
der gesellschaft macht was macht das
unter wirtschaftlichen gesichtspunkten
mit der gesellschaft und aus all diesen
verschiedenen perspektiven zusammen
müssen wir dann hinterher ein konzept
entwickeln und sagen so machen wir es
jetzt und dafür erarbeitet gerade die
leopoldina die grundlage
unsere gäste hier kommen ihre auskünfte
vielen dank für sie an sie zu uns
gekommen bin und vielen dank an unsere
user die uns verfolgt haben live stream
oder möglicherweise auch bei live
übertragung vielen dank und machen sie's
gut passen sie auf sich auf und alles
gute